things are getting more complicated for
ninjas deposed president Muhammad Basu
three weeks after the coup his former
guards want to charge him with treason
after sucking him
the government of Niger has to date
gathered the necessary evidence to
prosecute before the competent National
and international authorities the ousted
president and his local and foreign
accomplices for high treason and
undermining the internal and external
security of Niger following his
exchanges with the Nationals of foreign
heads of state and heads of
international organizations
political commentators say while the
charges against bazoom are weighty there
could also be a power struggle playing
out they are trying to see how they can
silence Brazil as a president
and then possibly end his own life
because once it's convicted it means he
spend that he's going to spend the rest
of his life in prison and he will not
gonna be relevant political in nature
the problem is that chances are there
for a civil war to erupt in Niger
the charges come hours after an attack
on a military base in the chilibrium
region north of the capital Miami that
killed seven soldiers it's the fourth
such attack since the military took
power last month
the cool leaders cite the lack of
security as one of the main reasons they
overthrew the democratically elected
president
but with these attacks on the rise
people are beginning to question the
motives of the coup on Sunday senior
religious figures from Nigeria met
Ninja's cool leaders who stated a
willingness to negotiate with the
regional block echoes
in neighboring Nigeria concerns are
mounting about the events in Niger as
refugees begin to cross its border
fearing an escalation attention is
building across the border while many
people in Nigeria are concerned about
possible military intervention many
Nigerians are worried about the
aftermath local CSA centuries of
cross-border trade and relationships
will be in Jeopardy as long as ninjas
military remain defiant we have started
receiving influx of people from Niger
but in their pocket some of them have
started seeking for Refuge here and it's
not only Nigeria that's watching its
concern
politicians and analysts on the
continent are worried about the speed at
which these schools are happening
especially in West Africa
Nigeria
foreign